how old's your daughter she's six
okay did you take your daughter to see
Star Wars I wanted to take her so bad to
see Star Wars but I showed her the Star
Wars Episode four the original Star Wars
I showed it to her and she was what she
didn't hate it but she wasn't she was
like okay I'm done and I'm well there's
the new one out she goes you know it she
talked that way - yeah she's good
right Mary she's she just can't she
can't experience joy anymore
wouldn't what's left she can ride it -
we'll bike she's done you know look at
that gorgeous sunset it's going down
I've seen it no she just was it just
wasn't her it just wasn't her thing and
I couldn't like I I didn't want to be
the the dad that's going to I'm gonna
stamp out a little clone of myself and
you're gonna enjoy this no matter what
like I didn't want to be the Star Wars
version of the football dad you know the
I didn't want to be the Star Wars
version of the Great Santini and grudges
browbeating her into liking Star Wars
and and I just was like you know what my
dad was a Marine my mom was a legal
secretary they didn't care about science
fiction and I found that on my own and
my daughter is gonna find her own thing
on her own and I'm gonna let her figure
out I'm not going to I'm not gonna you
know what she's into I know her big
thing is right now my little pony my B
is she okay she's into my little pony
the way that I was into Star Wars back
in 1977 she knows the whole world she
knows all the characters and good good
for her I don't know there was that much
to it it's my little pony well I I get I
don't eat all these get why would you
know that there was anything the Star
Wars unless you're really into it right
but I realized that I don't have the
time to absorb a new realm you know like
I
I did my absorbing with Star Wars I knew
everything about service I knew the name
of Dan gars the Bounty Hunter's ship the
punishing one I you I knew all
so now she's learning all the ins and
she's like sit down with me and let's
watch My Little Pony and she'll explain
these stories and I'm kind of half
listening but she's into it you know and
she and that's her thing now she's
watching My Little Pony the The
Adventures of these of well the main
characters named Twilight Sparkle and
Twilight Sparkle is a is a is a eunuch
well there's three kinds of ponies into
my little pony world
there's unicorns they can use magic then
there's the earth ponies like Pinkie Pie
and Applejack and then there are the
pegasi the basically the pegasi are a
Fluttershy and lightning that Rainbow
Dash for a book that is lightning that
is gonna say it's beginning you know
Twilight Sparkle is up in Canterlot with
Princess Celestia oh she's Princess
Celestia's library and Princess lights
is like you know you need to understand
how so she sends her down
it's a Ponyville I'm after she meets the
different ponies and you know also the
elements of harmony have gone missing
because you know Princess Celestia had
this twin but again this is my daughter
saying
[Applause]
hey thanks for watching please subscribe
to my youtube channel so they will stop
making me shoot these videos please